how do you push back on de-platforming
well who who would do it is it other
students is it faculty is it the
administration what's the Dynamics of uh
pushing back of basically because I
imagine
some of it is culture but imagine every
university has a bunch of students who
will protest basically every speaker and
it's a question of how you respond to
that protest well here's here's the
dirty little secret about like the big
change in 2014
um and and fire and meet me and height
um have been very clear that the big
change that we saw on campus was that
for most of my career students were
great
um on freedom of speech they were the
best constituency for free speech
absolutely unambiguously until about
2013 2014. and it was only in 2014 where
we had this very you know kind of sad
for us experience where suddenly
students were the ones advocating for
de-platforming and new speech codes kind
of in a similar way that they had been
doing in say like the mid 80s for
example but here's the Dirty Little
Secret
it's not this it's just the students
it's students and administrators some
sometimes only a handful of them though
working together to make uh to create
some of these problems and this was
exactly what happened at Stanford when
Kyle Duncan uh a fifth Circuit Judge
tried to speak at my alma mater and a
fifth of the class showed up to shout
him down
um it was a real showing of The of what
was what was going on that 10 minutes
into the shout down of a fifth Circuit
Judge and I keep on emphasizing that
because I'm a constitutional lawyer if
historical judges are big deals they're
one level below the Supreme Court
um you know about a fifth of the school
shows up to shut them down after 10
minutes of shouting him down an
administrator a Dei administrator gets
up with a prepared speech that she that
she's written that's a seven minute long
speech where she talks about uh Free
Speech maybe the juice isn't worth the
squeeze and we we we're at this law
school where people could learn to
challenge these norms so it's clear that
there was coordination you know amongst
some of these administrators and from
talking to students there they were in
meetings extensive meetings for a long
time they show up do a shout down then
they take an additional seven minutes to
to lecture the speaker on Free Speech
not being not the juice of free speech
not being worth the squeeze
um and then for the rest of it it's just
constant heckling
um after she after she leaves this is
clearly and this and something very
similar you know happened a number of
times at Yale where it was very clearly
administrators were helping along with a
lot of these disruptions so I think
every time there is a shout down at a
university the investigation should be
first and foremost did administrators
help create this problem did they do
anything to stop it because I think a
lot of what's really going on here is
the hyper bureaucratician of
universities with a lot more ideological
people who think of their primary job as
basically like policing speech more or
less they're encouraging students sorry
they're encouraging students who have
opinions they like
um to do shout Downs um and that's why
they really need to investigate this and
it is uh at Stanford the administrator
who who gave the prepared remarks um
about the juice not being worth the
squeeze she has not been invited back to
Stanford but she's one of the only
examples I can think of when these
things happen a lot where an
administrator clearly facilitated
something that was a shout down or a
de-platforming or resulted in a
professor getting fired or resulted in a
student getting expelled where the
administrator has got off scot-free or
probably in some cases even gotten a
promotion and so a small number of
Administrators maybe even a single
administrator
could participate in the encouraging and
the organization and thereby and power
the whole process and that's something
I've seen throughout my entire career
and the only thing is kind of hard to
catch this sort of in the act so to
speak and that's one of the reasons why
it's helpful for people to know about
this you know
uh because it was this amazing case this
was at University of Washington
um and we actually featured this in a
documentary made in 2015 20 that came
out in 2015 2016. called can we take a
joke
um and this was when we started noticing
something was changing on campus we also
heard that comedians were saying that
they couldn't use their Good Humor
anymore this was right around the time
that Jerry Seinfeld and Chris Rock said
that they couldn't they didn't want to
play on campuses because they they could
they they couldn't be funny
uh but we featured a case of a comedian
who wanted to do a musical called The
Passion of the musical making fun of The
Passion of the Christ with the stated
goal of offending everyone every group
equally it was very very much a South
Park Mission
um and it's an unusual case because we
actually got documentation of
Administrators buying tickets for angry
students and holding an event where they
where they trained them to to jump up in
the middle of it and Shout I'm offended
like they they bought them tickets they
sent them to this this thing with the
goal of shouting it down now
unsurprisingly when you send an angry
group of students to shut down a play it
it's not going to end at just I'm
offended
um and it got heated there were death
threats being thrown the um and then the
Pullman Washington police told uh Chris
uh Chris Lee the guy who made the play
that they wouldn't actually protect him
now it's not every day you're gonna have
that kind of hard evidence that that
that of actually seeing the
administrators be so uh so Brazen that
they recorded the fact that they bought
them tickets and sent them but I think a
lot of that stuff is it is going on and
I think it's the it's a good excuse to
cut down on one of the big problems in
higher education today which is hyper
bureaucratization